se perfila como el líder más poderoso
que ha tenido China desde Mao zedong
pero chiquitinto un camino accidentado
hacia lo más alto nacido en 1953 el
padre de shift fue uno de los miembros
fundadores del partido comunista y
expice Primer Ministro pero la suerte de
su familia empeoró cuando Mao ordenó una
purga de posible rivales para acabar con
cualquier rebelión en las filas del
partido
su padre fue encarcelado en 1962 y a los
15 años Sí fue enviado al campo para su
reeducación y trabajos forzados
esta dificultad inicial hizo poco
paradiso a ir a chi del partido
comunista se le permitió unirse a él en
1974 y comenzó a abrirse camino en las
filas hasta finalmente ser elegido
presidente de China en 2012
durante su gobierno shi consolidó El
Poder y eliminó el límite de dos
mandatos para los presidentes lo que en
teoría le permite permanecer en su cargo
indefinidamente Día tras día también ha
reforzado el control sobre casi todos
los aspectos de la vida en China
supervisando un cambio profundo en la
forma en que se dirige el país
Cuando entró Allí se Consideró que el
líder anterior hushingtown era demasiado
débil porque era un líder de consenso y
poder blando si sin fin centralizó el
poder en su propia figura y se centró en
intentar que el partido se sintiera
mucho más orgulloso de ese mismo como
partido
bajo el gobierno de China ha establecido
los llamados campos de reeducación en
chin yang para los fujigures y otros
grupos étnicos minoritarios las ong
dicen que están plagados y abusos contra
los Derechos Humanos Sí también
supervisó una brutal represión de los
movimientos prodemocráticos en Hong Kong
y prometió reunificarse con Taiwán
usando la fuerza si es necesario
Beijing también ha tomado medidas
enérgicas contra la disidencia en casa
el periodista chino jopping ha estado
cubriendo el partido comunista durante
años él dice que el mayor peligro que
enfrenta el país es que sí se convierta
en un dictador de por vida rodeado de
Seguidores ciegos
el poder de China tiene una gran
continuidad y la ventaja de esta
continuidad es que conduce a la
estabilidad de la política de China su
desventaja es que tenemos mucho miedo
mucha gente tiene mucho miedo de que él
realmente se convierta en un hombre que
nunca renuncie
en una Clara señal de la influencia e
importancia de Sí en 2017 el partido
comunista votó para escribir su
filosofía en la Constitución solo el
presidente Mao obeden shopping que
introdujeron reformas económicas han
recibido este alto honor